hello youtube chess lovers and my
friends this is gunjan here
and today we are going to discuss about
a trap against the french defense
now uh the good thing about this trap is
uh it's not necessary it can only occurs
in blood tournaments or let's say one or
three minutes game it can be occurred or
you can play as a weapon in tournaments
so you can even try in classical games
or even in rapid tournaments
and uh what i have done in this video is
so we'll go step by step towards the
trap
and uh
i will also show you the
sidelines which can occur if the trap
does not occur in your game
so in that case uh what should what you
should do and that will be my own
recommendation
so okay uh without wasting any time uh
let's start so
the trap is against the french defense
now french defense occurs occurs
uh when white starts with the e4
so we have more arrows like this so
white start with e4 and black responds
with e6 and after d4 d5
here uh i'm recommending you play e5 so
it's an advanced version of the french
now
the
most obvious response is the c5
and after c5 uh there is a line which
goes like
we play c3 like this
but
here i'll suggest a move
which is again a repetition of my last
strap in that trap i have shown you the
line which goes like this if black is
refused refuting to take that pawn and
if he's continues like a
normal developing move such as bishop d7
then we'll continue like bishop d3
and after knight c6 you can watch my
another video which i have highlighted
over here in this on this captions
uh you can try this tricky move knight
g5
which i only recommend if you're playing
blitz or the very quick game
otherwise uh classical tournaments
please don't try this you know in
classical or independent tournaments
what i suggest you go with the
main line which is e3 and please do
study if you are going to play this trap
in the tournaments
right
so
this is one way to tackle if
black is
refra refrain to capture that pawn
okay moving back
now
uh
there is a one waiting move black can do
which is uh it can play
black can play knight c6 and after
bishop d3
uh
now it can capture the pawn now
if it captured by the pawn it will
deviate to a main line but the main idea
is let's say if it kept you by the
knight
then here again
there are many lines exist
fritz recommend you can castle and then
after we kept recapturing that knight
you can play c3 so it's complete
gambiting the pawn
but instead of that i'm showing you a
very easy way to get an equal position
with some kind of space so the sample
line goes like this so you capture that
night and after black recaptures you
give this check
and after black blocked the check with
the bishop you just simply capture that
bishop and after black recapture with
the queen you simply regain the pawn
now the position is balanced so roughly
equal but white has a more space
advantage just because of this phone
you can see this pawn is cramping black
pieces to come out very freely and
you can have a good middle game from
here onwards
so i'm not going further
from here you can analyze your own so
back to our trap and
here
after
let's say either after black play knight
c6 or
it can capture this one very very
immediately which is c cross t4 and here
we'll continue with bishop d3
and you can see it's a transposition of
the last line so knight c6 and now i'm
recommending the move castle
now
here there are few moves for the black
and i'll i will suggest uh
my own recommendation
to each against each of this line so
first move we are going to have a look
which is a
kind of weird move which is g6
well it's logical where the the planning
is the knight is coming to e7 bishop is
coming to g7 and then black will castle
it's all smooth and good but the problem
is in the long run
uh black has this huge weakness this is
this is a hole in the black and in the
long run white can exploit this hole
so
we can straight away put this line in
rubbish because it's i can easily say
white is already better here
okay
uh another move
black can play is this move which is
f6
now
again against f6 there are many
variation exist even in the market
but there's one very simple way to
diffuse this uh again it's my own
recommendation if you don't have any
line from here onwards i recommend you
should play query too again it's a
theoretical line and a sample line can
go like this so after pawn takes you
take back with the knight
and if the knight takes knight then the
queen has a very good square so
uh most likely the general response from
the black is developing the king side so
knight f6 here i recommend you play
bishop f4
and after bishop d6 which looks very
logical attacking that knight
uh i recommend you play knight d2 and
after the castle by black you play
knight f3 and you can see now after all
the transition uh white has a nice
posted piece over here
and uh that will give you more than
enough compensation for the pawn
uh maybe a a more aggressive line can go
like this so black can try this tricky
move looking uh tricky looking move
which is knight to e4
which has the idea of
attacking our bishop or some kind of
tricks on that but we can simply defuse
this trick by playing nitros c6 so now
you can see it's attacking the queen so
black has to forcefully take this and
again we are going to take this bishop
so again you can see it's attacking the
attacking the rook and that's why uh
black has to forcefully take
with the knight because if you take with
the queen then the pawn will be crippled
so forceful variation is
knight takes and then we can regain the
pawn
and okay the material is balanced but
now compare
this bishop with this stupid bishop
because it's looking at his own pawns
and
more
and one more good advantage for the
white is there's a big juicy target over
here so what can force is like you know
for forces army for example it can go
like this
and target on this phone so it will be a
very very easy game for the white also
you can plan for attack on this week at
seven pawn
so that all kind of plants can come into
the picture and you all can agree this
is a very good position for the white
okay so that is about f6 and uh
what happened uh at this point uh
there are some other moves for example
there is most logical uh moves will be
the bishop moose okay black can play uh
this manual which is uh
knight goes to e7 and then knight goes
to g6 and then bishop will develop but
meantime bishop bishop will be in prison
and uh
like you know black has to wait for a
long time for the castle so the most
logical move at this position is to play
the bishop move now if the bishop has
been moved over to e7 then this knight
will locked in so it does not have any
future okay let me get rid of this
arrows so i can show you exactly what
i'm talking about so if the bishop is
move over here
then this knight has no good squares so
that's why this is no good so the bishop
has only two good squares so let's to
have a look at the first square which is
bishop to b4 it's look like a logical
square where bishop is looking at the
square so the rook cannot come to the
even
well in this case uh a very good line
goes like this so white plays first of
all a3 kicking that bishop and once the
bishop goes back
now you can play knight d2
now general line continues like this so
black is trying to you know cast on the
king side as soon as possible so he will
develop the knight to e7 and now you
play b4
and now there are two moves to
retrieving that bishop the first is
bishop goes to
b6
well here there's a one very easy way
to get back our pawn with a very good
positional advantage so the sample line
can go like this white first of all
protect or protect that e4 e5 pawn
and after uh
black play h6 now you may ask why that
is at six because
if
black castle over here then there is a
nasty sacrifice waiting for bishop takes
at seven and that i have also explained
in my another chess trap video so that's
why at this point h6 is very very
necessary so stopping the knight coming
to the g5
and here we'll continue with bishop to
b2 now you can see we are targeting this
pawn
so now already two pieces are attacking
that pawn and black is defending with
that two two pieces and let's say black
black play bishop d7 or the castle
either move in that case the very simple
is
knight goes to v3 and now you can see
there are three pcs attacking that pawn
and white will regain the pawn with a
better position
so this is a very simple line which if
you opponent play bishop b6
now if your opponent going to play
bishop to c7 after we play b4
then uh
again the plan is very very simple so
what we are going to do is
we play our bishop to here
knight goes over here our rook goes over
here and again we'll regain the pawn
and you can see
right now the black pieces are not
like actively developed so you can see
this queen is a kind of reliability
right now it does not have a good square
also this bishop does not have a good
square
so
uh it's a very good position for a white
and especially over
is a great asset
okay
so that is about bishop b4
now if
the most logical move here is bishop c5
which kind of over protecting that phone
and
this is most usual response will become
when you're playing this line and now
here i recommend a tricky move which is
e3
and
this is very very tricky move because
let's say if black goes on the king side
development so for example if black goes
like knight ge7
and after we play b4
uh i think uh
that pawn is gone let's see how so uh
there's one only one spare space for the
bishop so bishop goes back to b6 and
after you play
b5 knight goes to
a5 and after bishop b2
uh
by pawn because there is no way
black can hold on to that pawn
so that's why
it's very very important here for black
to stop b4 and that's why the most usual
response in instead of knight g's e7 is
to play a5 to stopping that one
stopping before so here we will continue
with rook e1
and after knight ge7 we will play knight
d2
now you may ask what exactly white is
doing over here
uh it seems like we have given up the
pawn and seems like we does not have any
plans right now we are not doing
anything we are just maneuvering our
pieces but we are not doing anything but
you will see
what an attacking plan might have
uh
okay so after knight d2 again black has
a true response if it's going to castle
then he has to face this move which is
bishop tax h7 and again i recommend you
go through my another video which i have
especially it's known as a chest strap 2
and greek gift
so i recommend you go through that video
and
i can show you some sample examples like
if the king takes then the knight check
and after king goes to back queen
h5
and the fritz is showing that
it's almost lost made in 10 moose
at least
so
that explains that black has to play
first of all this move
knight g6 to stop that uh
bishop takes at seven
and uh here we will continue
with this knight maneuvering so knight
goes back to f1
now again
the most logical move is castle
but before castle
black can play this move so either way
it will be a transposition you can see
this queen right now does not have any
good squares where f6 g5 or h4 does not
have this squares
also
it does not have any good square because
if it goes to d7 then it blocking the
own bishop so most logical square for
the queen is at this point is queen goes
to b6 with the one married which it's
stopping right now this bishop
to go anywhere because otherwise this
pawn will be hanging
so it's kind of
black which is uh black queen which
moves to the b6 the purpose of
developing a piece a queen with active
square and also stopping white for
further development
anyways uh white will play knight to g6
and after castle
now
we are all set up to play our trap and
our trap starts with this move
knight to h5
and uh
i can't tell you uh
probably i have i just known this trap
from last uh probably two to three
months and uh
already 20 people are victim of this
trap i got like exactly same position in
20 games and i won all of them
so it's that much dangerous this
position for the black
now
let's see some of the games from here
some of my own games so one of my
opponent play here bishop
d7 and this is a big blunder
now
i wonder if you can spot uh amazing move
here i'll give you some time
think about it
okay the move is
the ship at six
now in my game my opponent thought that
uh i made a like slippery move so my
bishop i just i want to put my bishop on
g5 instead of that i put it at six so he
immediately took this of course it was a
like three minutes again so it's not
accurate game
but after this knight check he really
realized that it's a lost position
because uh
either king goes to g7 or in the game he
played ratchet then i simply snap off
that bishop and now you can see it's not
only we are regaining the material but
now we are
forking the green and a rope so it's
almost lost position for black
so that is one thing can be occurred and
let's say if even if the black does not
accept that bishop uh
more or less the bishop will capture
that g pawn and that bishop will be
really monster on sitting on that g7
so that will be good great for white
in another game one of my opponent
played this kind of waiting move so he
played uh this move a4 so idea is very
simple he wants to play the knight from
here to here
and uh
like gaining some kind of space on the
queen side
but
to surprise to be surprised uh
white can play the same bishop at six
and uh let's say if
black is denying to take that bishop in
that case the very simple and very
effective plan for the white is
to take this pawn then the move move the
bishop over here then queen goes either
to c1 or d2 and then it slide across
to
six and then
setting up checkmate
and it's very very effective
and
very
hard to stop the plan for the black and
that is why it's very very very much
essential for black right now right now
to take this bishop
and after
uh in my one of my game my opponent took
this bishop after a long thinking
uh
can you guess
a winning continuation from over here
i'll give you a few minutes try to find
out a winning continuation
okay the winning continuation starts
like this so you play queen to either
queen to c1 or queen to d2 more or less
they are same
right and simply it's threatening to
take the pawn and delivering the
checkmate over here
for example over here
so
uh in one of my game my opponent play
this move king gets hit but
to his horror he find out he lost
and i took this pawn
and after he thought he stopped the mate
now comes to another blow which is
knight to g5 and now you can see there's
two way
uh white is check meeting the black so
one is uh it can take this pawn by the
queen or another is take this one by the
knight and that will be smooth this mate
so
that kind of attacking position you get
from this kind of
bishop sacrifice
okay so
uh
after this uh in one of my game my once
my opponent took the bishop when i
played queen to c1 he realized the
danger uh exists in this uh trap and
i think he played the only move
which is possible to stop the checkmate
and which is either f6 or movieplay
which is f5
and now there's a very simple
continuation here for me so i played on
person so i took that one
and you can see
black group cannot take the bone so he
played rook to f7
uh
stopping the checkmate anyways i took
that pawn and after he played this move
bishop to f8
i simply
put my queen over here and now you can
see so many threats over here
okay so this bishop is lining up to take
the knight and with the check
if it's not enough
i can play my knight over here and then
two pieces are attacking this knight
and look at the whole queen side for the
black so rope the ship the queen and the
knight they all are
probably on the wrong side
because they were king black king wants
them to defend the castle but they are
so far away
and this kind of fun you are getting in
this line so
especially i was amazed by you can see
this this night maneuverings for example
it goes from here to here then
from here and it goes over here and
finally our bishop unleashed here
so this poland was very very effective
and it's it's kind of very hard for
black to
see this one is coming unless he
probably know about this plan
and
this this turned out very well for me
so i wish you best of luck
if you're planning to play this trap in
your games
and uh just i just uh suggest you try in
some of the blitz or the trim it's game
before you're trying in big tournaments
and
it's very very effective even it can
works uh over 2000 plus player
uh
i wish you best of luck for playing this
trap uh well thank you for watching my
video and feel free to comment on my
video i'll post a new video soon bye